the Joe Rogan experience rulemaking baby
you had some french fries and David Lee
Roth that we made with clear the legend
animal Jamie you were there what did you
see I saw a French fire - yes I hear -
melon listen MGM steakhouse then cooking
that [ __ ] those french fries and
anything of an animal fat guaranteed
they're too delicious I didn't see it I
didn't see it even in McDonald's if you
get McDonald's fries apparently they
cook them in some [ __ ] disgusting fat
well that's what makes them taste so
good what does make McDonald fries taste
good they're pretty good but they're not
my favorite I don't know I get confused
when people say they're better than
in-and-out fries Oh what I like fries
that tastes like potatoes oh yeah even
the now fries are far superior
I don't like fries that tastes like
potato fries better than McDonald's I do
personally feel like you know who I had
beef with that about where candy
Alexander from Newsradio she was the
first person to like we went and got in
and out like for the holes the whole
group of us and she got McDonald's fries
she went got McDonald's problem why'd
you get McDonald's fries she's like [ __ ]
those [ __ ] fries those in-and-out
fries but what I didn't understand they
can be okay but they're so hit-or-miss
that they can miss bad to me they're
remarkably consistent with Five Guys
fries five guys are the king of fries
yes there are two options they have kid
they're real they have the [ __ ]
potatoes and bags sitting in their
goddamn store just to let you know [ __ ]
we're using these potatoes and then they
taste that baggage shake it in there and
cut it up
they have cajun fries mmm so they win
you have another option you got spicy
fries that are goddamn delicious
I have to stop by there and then you
don't have to crack packets to get your
ketchup they have a giant tub of the
ketchup he squirt that [ __ ] a nice
little
a little paper cup you can shower and
have that and catch up McDonald's had
that homeless people will be under it
squirt mustard in my
[Applause]